[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEVON RODRIGUEZ:
Excuse me, miss.
I drew you.
This is fire!
Yo!
[LAUGHTER]
I'm Devon Rodriguez, and I'm
the most followed visual artist
on TikTok.
Today, I have over 25 million
followers and counting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[HISSING]
And in the next
30 days, I'm going
to teach you techniques that
will give you the confidence
to paint anything in the world.
So in this class, I'm going to
teach you my secret techniques
that I've never
taught anyone before.
I like to smash the bristles.
It makes the edges super soft.
And I'm going to break down
my process step by step.
I'm going to be teaching
you about materials, how
to apply the colors,
mix the colors, how
to blend your tones together,
how to draw proportion,
understanding light, the
importance of reference
photos--
everything you need to know
to paint the portrait.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'll teach you how to level
up your drawing and painting
skills, even if you're
just starting out.
So by the time we're
done with this class,
you're going to have your
own 9 by 12 oil painting.
We're going to
have a lot of fun.
[LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]